- [Interviewer] So anyway,
where are you from originally?
- Houston, Texas.
- [Interviewer] Houston.
And how long you been out here?
- [Honey Bun] For almost too months.
- [Interviewer] Oh, you're brand new.
And what brought you out to LA?
- [Honey Bun] To get in this rehab program
called (indistinct).
- [Interviewer] Yeah, down the street.
What's your drug?
- Crack.
- [Interviewer] Crack, how
long you been doing that?
- On and off from about 18, 19 years.
- [Interviewer] Wow,
what age did you start?
- I just relapsed when I got
out of here July the 5th.
I was six and a half years clean.
- [Interviewer] You were clean?
- For six and a half years.
- [Interviewer] What
triggered you to go back?
- The people, people, places and things.
- [Interviewer] Life.
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] And stress.
And tell me about your childhood.
Did you grow up with one
parent, both parents?
- I growed up with my mother.
She was a hard black and working woman.
She made sure we got our
education and graduated.
- [Interviewer] What was the house like?
You have brothers and sisters?
- I had a twin brother and
a 40-some year old brother.
It was good.
I had a good living
until my mother passed.
- [Interviewer] When
did your mom pass away?
- 2002, October the 1st, 2002.
- [Interviewer] So how old were you then?
- 22.
- [Interviewer] And where
did you go from there?
- In and out of prison,
jumping state to state.
Now in California.
- [Interviewer] What
were you in prison for?
- [Honey Bun] Prostitution,
aggravated assault
with a deadly weapon, attempted murder.
- [Interviewer] Attempted murder?
Tell me about that.
- [Honey Bun] Well, I was out there
whoring, scoring and blowing.
And this trick thought he
was just gonna take my area
of my body, and wasn't having it,
so I shot him in his nick
and I shot him in the back of the head.
But he survived.
He pulled through.
- [Interviewer] How many
years did you do for that?
- [Honey Bun] No, it was self-defense,
since they had it on camera.
- [Interviewer] So you didn't do any time?
- [Honey Bun] No, I just stayed in county
for almost two years
of fighting that case.
- [Interviewer] And do you
have children of your own?
- [Honey Bun] No, I'm 39
with no children, no kids.
- [Interviewer] And what do you
see for your life from here?
What do you want to do?
- [Honey Bun] I want
to get off the streets.
I want to go back home so
I can get it back together.
- [Interviewer] You did it once before.
Do you still have contact
with your family at all?
- [Honey Bun] No.
- [Interviewer] How did you
first get introduced to crack?
- I used to see my auntie smoke it.
When we was about eight or
nine, me and my twin brother,
my aunt used to have
me and my twin brother
fix her crack pipes
so we already knew how to fix 'em up
and we used to see her.
And I got curious one day.
I was 16, turning 17, in 11th grade,
and I got curious one
day and I wanted to see
what the crack do to make my auntie
destroy my whole granny
house (indistinct),
to see what make her take
everything out room by room,
one at a time, to search
for money and stuff.
I wanted to see what make her do all that,
why the crack make her do
that and now I see why.
- [Interviewer] So you've seen
all kinds of crazy stuff at night.
What kind of stuff have you seen and done?
- I have been raped, robbed,
and ran down the street buck naked.
(indistinct) prostitutes and tricks
been on a freeway and
didn't care, having sex.
I've seen a lot of stuff.
- [Interviewer] How much money do you make
typically in a night?
- Every night?
About four something.
- [Interviewer] $400?
- 400-some dollars.
- [Interviewer] How many guys is that?
- That's six.
- [Interviewer] It's pretty good.
And that pays for your crack habit?
- And my room, clothing
and food, and hygiene.
- [Interviewer] Well, be safe out there.
Good luck with everything.
- Thank you.
- [Interviewer] Hope you get clean.
- Pray for me.
- [Interviewer] Thank you.
- Thank you.